hello Jayden Elite what's up what's
going on Tim Jin Diego Hutton Romeo jimz
extreme Kyle
Ridley Elite what's going on guys
Darkness under the
wind oh they're piling in now what's up
everyone ready for Loki season 2 episode
two just pulling It Up on Disney plus
right
now cool what's going on excited to see
what happens this
episode oh this season one I was like
it's out already nope that was season
one they teased me so this episode I
think with the because I know everyone's
gonna ask I'm just gonna put this out
there so I think like with the
credits it's 49 minutes I think no maybe
a little bit shorter maybe like 48
minutes maybe exactly as long as the
other one yeah though hey thanks David
inyang appreciate that what's going on
everybody
Nas love from South
Africa Elite
Mo extreme Kyle wolf Darkness year funny
gaming what's going on Jose what's going
on Wolf the Star Wars collector yo what
up Star Wars fans up in
here the devil
father uh yeah yeah yeah yeah we got
about 40 minutes till it comes up billyb
entertainment is this a slow episode
[Music]
um well it's
interesting question because the last
episode I would say wasn't like you know
action jammed packed
um but I I guess I would say out
of out of
the I don't know there's some really
cool components of this episode yeah
they might not like run around as much
but they they do there's Parts where
they're on the timeline R running around
and stuff like that so so
yeah oh my gosh lethal Nate you just got
your members only this one yeah this
hoodie that's so funny I'm glad you got
it glad you got it
buddy I think it also has no it doesn't
I thought it had a badge or something
somewhere where was on the hood there
was
something there was something that it
had somewhere I can't remember I thought
it was on the hood maybe
no there's something else somewhere on
this thing that I
uh that I thought it said Cosmic Wonder
on or something I guess it doesn't
actually say Cosmic wonder huh it just
says
CW yeah yeah
yeah people are suggesting that Loki
pruned himself
uh what what Loki would be my my
question back to
that dang gaming stuff that's intense
hope you're all right stay safe the best
you
can uh farshad talk a bit about this
episode okay you're gonna you're G this
is the uh this isn't really spoiler
since it's in the trailer this is the
zaniac episode where you see uh Loki and
mobus go back in time where they dressed
up in Texas
cedos and there's a really really
cool really really cool um
TVA device that's used in this episode I
don't know what it's called at one point
in time I believe Mobius called it Gizmo
but that could just you know anything
like a gizmo right that you play with
I'm a little sick today so if I'm
sniffling I'm sorry I'm going need a
cough drop right
now but uh
yeah you know Jun FAL hello love back
Ramirez
Productions my best bet is that Ren
Slayer prun
Loki wolf do I like Pokemon yes you
probably can't see it this little yellow
thing right there is a
Pikachu uh Pokemon was like o that was
like my childhood I collected so many
cards and I played all the games I have
all the games still I still play all the
games
um the newer games today like they're
fun to me but they have a lot of like
they make you do a lot of side quests
and I'm just like dude I just want to
like play Pokemon fight Gym Leaders do
the Elite 4 like that's all I really
want to
do Leonardo what's going on yo
back Lea Lea man hello hello hello movie
theater plot
point do we get to see
JM this episode Jim Jim j oh Jonathan
Majors
um I don't know if I want to answer that
keep you guys on your
toes uh I will say three and
four he's like the main point of three
and four I'll give you that how about
that so episode three and four it's like
all about Jonathan majors
a variant Mr Anderson what's going on
woof woof welcome welome
welcome uh Billy Bug
entertainment
uh you're you're pretty you're kind of
right on that I I don't know episode
three they're all really good in their
own ways this might be the slower of
them but there's some really cool parts
to it and there's some good scenes it's
all important I would say like I've said
one and four are my
favorite but three
gets the pacing when it when we get to
three the pacing gets a lot it like
ramps up a
lot bins hello
Chaz de biano what's up Michael what's
going
on for all time always Jose what's going
on Patrick no what's going
on oh yeah the time the time change for
these releases have done wonders for a
lot of people me including just
because I oh guys I can't even tell you
like I mean I'm sure you know most of
you know that I stopped doing the watch
parties and it's because like not only
my mental health but my physical health
I could not continue to do them
because what they started
at 1:00 a.m. my time and then you know
you watch through it and then you
discuss it after so it's like
2:30 by the time I actually start
working on the breakdown and like a
breakdown is not something you can
really rush through I mean you could but
it would end up being really really bad
right
so you know you take a few hours to do
the breakdown and plus the editing and
the thumbnail and everything like that
and it's like yeah I would be going to
bed at like 6:00 a.m. 7: a.m. in the
morning and that would screw up my
entire work schedule week schedule you
know waking up and everything like that
and by the time I finally bounce back
bam time for another watch party party
um time for another episode Loki so I
can't tell you how much
this uh change of the release times is
has been a big benefit for
me yes exactly Mr Anderson oh gosh you
had school at the time too when it was
3:00 a.m. yeah Elite you're on the East
Coast then yeah um yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
uh I haven't watched gen V let see what
uh what was that Marcella gamer J V is
out yeah I haven't I haven't been
watching
that yeah when do we get to see Sylvie
uh you you see her in this episode you
saw her at the in the post credits of
last episode so oh actually we saw her
in the uh in the elevator too she was
there in last episode yeah in the
elevator oh dang you're funny gaming
what's going on gaming stuff dang that's
intense uh Chaz yes I did I made this
breakdown at Advance uh the only problem
is is the foot I I mentioned this last
time the footage I have has my watermark
on
it big old Watermark of my name on it so
I can't use any of the footage so the
editing uh has to be done post post the
release of the show so we can grab the
footage that way I forgot to I'm
assuming y'all hear
me gonna te test the stream right
now
oh okay good good good good good just
making
sure
cool put that there in case I need the
I'm gonna need the chat on my
phone when the when it
starts where wolf where did you get your
name Cosmic Wonder from so before I
answer that I
would I would like you all to put in the
chat where you think I got my name from
because I don't think anybody will
really probably guess it
so thanks my car what's going on Shadow
shaking What's Going On Everybody Emma
welcome yeah no worries Emma appreciate
you stopping
by Alexis lucky I saw four episodes
yeah I mean I'm grateful but sometimes
I'm like I mean I I really wish I could
watch everything fresh with everybody
and um Cliffhangers are are a thing for
looky season 2 that's that's all I'm
going to really say
here uh no not a random
site uh space kind of yeah you're not
wrong there extreme Kyle you be quiet
you stupid Deputy 1024 I don't see in
Discord Nick is in the Discord waiting
for you right now just so you know
Deputy D
that's funny Mr Anderson what's going on
con donaho donaho there we
go
uh I'm trying to figure out
um a good strain of smoke no
no
um uh when I started the channel I was
wanting to put a heavy focus on both
Marvel and
DC um but unfortunately DC just you know
lost like a ton of
smoke uh the hype and everything
just like they lost a lot of steam
and it was hard to keep up with
everything ultimately and people just
kind of didn't want to hear it for a
while and the fandom got really tough
with this SN verse and everything for a
while uh and Marvel was huge so I just
kind of focused on Marvel for a bit more
DC stuff come up in the future for sure
when the new DC you launches which James
gun which I'm excited about but
originally I wanted a name that was both
from Marvel and DC
so having said that can you now guess
kind of where the name comes
from Carlos Aon sup Cosmic Love hey
thanks so much hey my whole family is
from Corpus Christie Texas so fellow Tex
in here I don't live there now but yo
Adam Matthew Smith what's going on man
po Blood and Honey right now I haven't
seen that one that uh I didn't know if I
wanted like a childhood character of
mine turned into a murder the same thing
for like that Grinch one right wasn't
there like a grinch one so
yeah can anyone tell is it released
episode two no it will be released in 31
minutes 31
minutes how many more yeah no 31 31
minutes
yeah uh gaming stuff I there's not like
an official change but I have heard that
yes Marvel is is we're probably looking
at 2028 release state for Secret
Wars
probably how close have I been to being
in an MCU or DC
movie if I have been close I don't know
about it I've never talked with anybody
like about being it I have one time told
Disney when Disney put out free guy and
they had a bunch of gamers in it like
like Pokémon man and ninja and everybody
I did was like Hey if there's ever like
a Marvel movie you need like real life
people to talk about Marvel in the movie
hit me up uh that would be the closest
I've ever gotten and it was just you
know I obviously meant it for real and
and they knew I meant it for
real but that that was me saying hey if
ever and you know that it was like a
laugh back like oh yeah for sure and you
know so it was kind of just like
um yeah kind of like a br I'm assuming
they like brushed it off but if it ever
did happen like if they ever decided to
put YouTubers in like an MCU movie I
would hope I'm
considered maybe but I don't know there
are bigger channels than mine of course
right so yeah I don't know but I've
never like been in active talks with
like Kevin fagy or anything like that
I've met I met
him
twice met him twice very briefly both
times
um yeah so maybe one day that would be
really cool what you
want Hello Bella Bella that's a funny
funny name I remember that remember that
channel thanks farad appreciate that
hello to IR
Ireland what is it what does it mean to
wipe out prune timelines kill all life
in the universe including celestials as
yeah like everything T-Mac literally
just think of just existence being
erased
yeah is there a reason they are doing
the show this way premiering on a set
time and
day Le I'm not not too sure what you you
mean by that like you you're talking
about the time change or is there you
talking about
like specific spe Al why they chose this
time and date CU I I the the new time I
love I think it's just you know I
actually think it's so they can get
better numbers the premier day because
by releasing this at what 6 6 p.m.
Pacific Time what 9 on the East
Coast you're probably going to get a lot
more people tuning in for the premieres
of each episode rather than 3:00 a.m. on
the East Coast right in
12 so do I collect H toys yeah I
actually have a whole box in the corner
of hot toys like a lot of different
ones
yeah yeah what got me into Marvel
honestly man I read
Comics since like before like really
since I can remember and then uh the the
animated stuff really like I can vividly
remember just sitting at my
home when as a kid watching just you
know Spider-Man X-Men animated series
like yeah that's I mean it's like my my
childhood I think like you can look at
my personal Instagram that I don't
really post to that much and scroll
through it and find a picture of me when
I'm
like five years old and I'm dressed up
as Wolverine like for Halloween like
I've always and and that's from probably
the Animated Series probably yeah
watching Animated Series yeah I don't
know just since a kid I've always it's
just been what I've loved and when the
MCU started well I mean really before
the MCU started you know when 2000 when
the X-Men started that was like crazy
for me cuz Wolverine is my favorite hero
but then um yeah but when the MCU
started all started be connected and the
possibility of everything started
happening yeah it
just wanted to start a YouTube channel
and did it
so yeah
um gaming stuff your birthday is the
19th of October my birthday is 29th of
October this month so we're pretty close
Jeff to yes blade is still happening it
is still happening po thanks for that
Super Chat 25 more minutes yeahuh yep
was that the master
no oh so po I I almost thought like your
I did there was a little bit of glare
looked like your uh icon was the master
chief for a second
you rafy Chow hurry will there be
another Avengers movie after Secret Wars
yeah of course yeah um I think Galactus
is coming in the Fantastic 4 film
yeah Stefan what is more important sleep
or lowy season two episode two I mean
you're asking the wrong guy you're you
know what my you know what my opinion is
gonna
be Lily's fandom mainly Marvel okay not
look you related but what do you think
about moonnight season 2 being released
do you think it'll happen sooner at all
um first and foros I love to moonight
really did love that series love Oscar
Isaac um
I I do believe there's going to be a
season two I I just you know I think
recently they've released a lot of stuff
about how you know one of the main
Riders left mid first season and there
were some problems but they they seem to
like regroup pretty well and I think
that's definitely in their plans moonn
night's definitely coming back for sure
for sure Rico was I a tunami kid yes
Dragon Ball Z tunami man that was uh
that was a little further on in my
childhood maybe when I was like uh you
know what I can't even tell maybe when I
was like nine or
10 yeah something like that I'm in in on
October 29th this month so in like
couple weeks I will be
34 I
think you lose track yes 30 34 sup sup
suu I'm assuming you're in a game
AJ uh do
I don't you know I heard about that I
heard about blade possibly being like a
back in time film um I think that's what
they're doing with the Fantastic 4 so it
wouldn't
um surprise me I'm honestly okay with
that too if the if the story is done
right I heard that there there was a
report recently that they were rewriting
the script
again excuse me um I heard that's not
true they're just changing some things
so I mean I guess it technically is true
they are rewriting it but not from like
scratch they're taking what they
currently have and are going to rewrite
some of what they already
have uh farshaw which Marvel project am
I most excited for exception of Deadpool
The Avengers Fantastic
Four yeah fantastic I mean ah Doctor
Strange
3 honestly I'm pretty excited for a lot
of them coming up I'm even I'm excited
for the Marvels it's not tracking very
well right now
but we'll
see
uh jedadiah aaya if I was given huge MCU
character play be
Wolverine for sure I would play
Wolverine
so there you go Ric yeah you and I are
probably watching it all the same same
thing tunami uh Dragon Ball Z man yeah I
remember wakanda will what's up man are
they still doing wakanda series next
year o you know it's really hard to say
anything about a certain time right now
because of the strikes and everything so
I don't want to like definitively say
anything but it is going to it it will
be happening for sure and there is uh
and there's also like an animated wakana
series coming out as well I don't know
when but that that was kind of announced
as well too so yeah uh oh gosh yeah
Patrick no I can't wait for them either
yeah um Adam the Marvel man what's my
top Fe F top five favorite MCU movies
that's really
hard
definitely uh infinity War
endgame the first Avengers
film
uh the the first Iron Man Thor
Ragnarok shanqi I think that's six but
that kind of gives you a feel of like
where I'm at with my my top
ones yeah there you go
uh yeah we are getting what if season
two in December Danny Campos that is
true yes thanks Kyle be sick Wolverine
thanks appreciate
that appreciate that uh Emanuel
Andrade do I think there's going to be a
reset yeah
um I think the universe and this is like
so this is something I noticed for
lowkey season 2 episode 1 and and two
and when went three whatever they look
at the time Loom and specifically what
Obie said in the first one remember how
he said like excuse me it's raw
time but he calls them at some point in
time branches going into the the loom to
create one timeline so I'm like so
really the what they're doing is
funneling the Multiverse into one
timeline so they already are combining a
lot of different timelines into into one
which is very interesting to think about
how that would actually work obviously
we're thinking thinking about something
fake possibly being real how would that
work not sure um but it makes me wonder
like I If you know if
they they even so they have the
Multiverse even with that Multiverse
being loomed into one Universe there's
still branches that come out of that
right so I'm just sitting they're like
what if the time Loom is just completely
destroyed and it's raw time and a raw
Multiverse like that's what I think is
ultimately going to lead to the true
Multiverse uh you
know happening I don't remember the
question I got off on the tangent there
oh reset yeah so um it seems like the
the time Loom is like forcing a bunch of
timelines in the one main timeline I
think we might get that again with all
the broken universes so people left over
from the broken broken universes will
all be shoved into one and we'll
essentially start over and I think it's
a good idea because it won't erase
anything especially so if you have
people left over from the 616 Universe
they'll remember everything that
happened and it's not like it never
happened but they're simply in a new
universe where it's fresh and new I
think it's a good idea if that's what
they decide to do that's my own Theory
so far shot yeah the Marvels and um loky
on the same day which was an interesting
choice by Marvel Studios I wonder if
they thought that
would increase sales or something for
whatever reason I don't know why um you
think they would have waited like a week
or a day and I'm sure it'll come out the
day before right like you probably catch
like a 10 o'clock sh or something like
that you
know
yeah spider Dan 299 that's pretty funny
your boss didn't buy it huh
Barton Bagus um it's it's so hard to
describe time especially when Loki the
series is even breaking its own rules by
stating like you know time doesn't exist
in the TVA and then like oh yes it does
and like no it doesn't well I guess it
does right it's
uh it's it's hard it's hard
to to kind of wrap your head
around
but hold on does that mean that time
could Branch back on itself yes I think
so but I'm saying that right now as
someone who doesn't they haven't really
told us all the rules yet right so
that's what I'm kind of waiting
for that's I'm kind of waiting for Mr
Anderson uh something excited about
seeing the Marvels I'm actually really
excited to see them all switched places
in them fight I think that's a
cool hurdle to get over at first but
than advantage to be used against darb
Ben I think that'd be really cool also
um I think decent amount of people know
that um I'm really into uh Korean
culture because of uh I grew up with it
in my
childhood and
um uh I speak Korean and I watch a lot
of kdramas and I listen to a lot of
K-pop and um Park sojun who's a Korean K
drama actor is in the Marvel so I'm
really excited for him as well he is
going to be Prince
Yan who Carol's going to have a
relationship with in some way no
spoilers in case you haven't watched my
videos on that so
but uh have you heard that Daredevil
bornean hit the reboot button of course
yeah
um so what it seems like right now is
Marvel Studios is
really it seems like they're
really they have noticed what fans are
saying they have noticed some some
disappointment and they have noticed
their numbers drop for streamings and
for their shows and for their movies I
think they've really just kind of
noticed that all and are like you know
what we really need to step it
up and when they sit back and look at a
project and they don't think it's up to
par they fire people and they say start
over and I think that's fine and I think
that's what you should do right um they
done this isn't the first time they did
it with blade right they did it now with
King Dynasty and Secret Wars like it's
what they do and hopefully it results in
better quality overall I think
storytelling has actually been their
shortcoming recently I think they could
step it up with the writing and the
storytelling to be quite
honest
so Loki was in the future yes you have
to keep that in mind
uh I don't know
about I I don't know about Tony Stark
returning in Sam Wilson's Captain
America 4 I wouldn't hold on to that
thought Manasses
nento I I haven't heard anything about
that at all and it doesn't seem like it
uh what happen Galaxy geks what's going
on wanted to swing by show some love
wanted to come on before my reaction to
Loki love the channel sweet thanks
thanks a bunch thanks a bunch and you
guys can check out Galaxy Geeks as well
check out the reaction appreciate that
um I am excited for Captain America
Brave New World I actually really am I
really am really
am wait did I misunderstand that one no
you did say Tony Stark returning no I I
think of anything maybe old Chris Evans
uh sorry not Chris Evans uh Captain
America old Steve Rogers appearing maybe
you know they haven't really said he
died yet or you know what he did so
maybe but I I don't expect Tony Stark in
Captain America
for and Valkyrie will reveal herself to
be Loki H
um yeah
yeah that'd be funny but no I I think
Loki is going to take over the TVA I
really
do I really do really
do uh for those asking we got 14 minutes
I will refresh just to make
sure yep still not out 14 minutes I
believe until it comes out
so
uh Darkness under the wind no if the
ending of look of season 2 had K killing
uh multiversal Heroes as he got closer
to the main not at all in fact I would
love to see that and if some things that
I've
heard about Secret Wars are
true and about Ted bolt 3 are
true I'm talking like stuff I can't put
on my my channel because it's like like
there are like certain leaks that are
obviously like too too much and that's
when uh so like I have gotten called by
Marvel security before and it's not a
fun
call it's not it's not a fun
conversation and I've gotten called by
Disney before stating that Marvel
security called them
so there's some things you really can't
talk about um when you're known and work
with them right if I was one of those
people out there that didn't work with
them it'd be whatever
but um if what I've heard is true and I
think it is uh you're going to like what
happens I think it's going to be done in
a clever
way yeah I I spider Dan I'm thinking
that Loki and Sylvie take control of the
TVA if not definitely Loki I think
that's I think that I did a video and I
think that's like Loki's glorious
purpose I really
do
um so Emanuel the trailers do show the
TVA Fallen part and there is something
that I haven't seen yet that I don't
know is there's a part in the trailers
that that Loki says to OB like what
could we have done different and it
makes it seem like they're about to die
and then Loki is going to go like back
in
time um so I'm not like I don't really I
I haven't seen any of that yet um so I
don't know what direction they're going
to go with
that so
yeah I don't I don't I don't even
know I'm very excited for the end very
excited for the end uh will J majers be
K after loky season 2 is over I hope so
I think that all depends on his
trial hey Ryan Nome thanks for Super
Chat we will see a reunion with Bruce
and general Ross Captain 4 movie yeah I
think so I really
do po you're not wrong they very well
could be which is why I'm not giving
away any secrets
thanks for super chats all appreciate
them
all
um oh yeah oh totally Javier Javier
Portillo Portillo yeah um I mean there
are people responsible for you know
trying to make sure like the big stuff
doesn't get out and if it does tracking
down you know who let it out because
it's obviously somebody like internally
telling somebody something
right um
the TVA could be destroyed or the TVA
could be the saviors of
everything uh
kamoka um my theory in the video that I
did is that the TVA is necessary they
don't necessarily have to make sure no
Branch timelines come out but you have
to monitor the timelines the branch
timelines because if you don't then
kangs will be loose so my theory was
that you could monitor the timelines and
see when a Kang or Nathaniel Richards
right is about to like or rise and then
from there you can either kill him or
you know take out the timeline then just
to be safe but that way you don't have
to kill every single timeline and
clearly they have the capacity to
monitor all these brand timelines
so yeah we'll
see uh somebody said something about
yeah uh the last live stream I did got
copyrighted because of some footage I
show showed so I just I'm not going to
show as much
today so no big
deal that that so the copyright stuff A
lot of times that's just like an
automatic YouTube thing uh companies set
up things with YouTube to automatically
claim stuff right it's not like a real
person going through YouTube channels
and just you
know copyrighting stuff although they do
that you know but
uh yeah uh does your sources from those
companies that give YouTubers news get
in
trouble does your sources from those
companies like give YouTubers get in
trouble I don't know about companies but
just the people the sources in
general yeah I mean there's a there's a
reason a lot of these people are
unyms7hu
I'll talk to them on Twitter and such
and um I don't know their names right
and I don't I don't ask right you know
um they're doing what they
do and you know I don't want to know
their names actually you know I don't
want Marvel like asking me for stuff and
because then I'm in a weird situation
you know what I mean so yeah I don't I
don't I know them I talk to them but I
don't like know them know them right you
know they're their scoopers are doing
what they can they're Anonymous right
and for a good reason because you
know they could get sued for what
they're doing
yeah Lucas tabs can I get a
h I'll give you that one right there
just because it's been a while since
I've heard those the H that's so
funny those were so big for a long
time I remember You' just be like out in
random public places and people would
just yell like can I get a h yeah and
people would just yell it so funny the
power of the internet
right uh far shot I think Deadpool 3 is
going to have that much hype uh you know
marketing is really a big deal when it
comes
to you know how much hype a show has it
really is so the strike should
definitely be over I mean they're going
to have to be over for Deadpool to
resume filming um so by then we should
be all right I'm I'm worried
about the Marvels I just I did my a
video you know a while ago saying it's
going to tank not because I wanted to
tank but because I just I think it's set
up to fail and it's already tracking
pretty poorly
so I really want it to do well but I
just I just don't think I just don't
think it is sadly it's already not kind
of doing well hey we got what seven
minutes seven
minutes yeah Darkness on the win I don't
I I don't think Deadpool could fail yeah
I really don't think so I think Deadpool
is just people are just Hugh Jackman
Wolverine's coming back I mean come on
and the other two movies were successful
with just Ry Reynolds leading it I mean
come on it's got to be successful it's
got to be
successful do I think K killed Iron Man
in endgame that might be revealed in
secret Wars rafie uh I don't think so AJ
get out of here with your jungle Cru 2o
if I hear anything you'll be the first
person that I tell I promise you if I
hear anything you know it's the rock
he's going to make movies he's going to
come back you already know
it
uh Warren what do I think is better dror
strange 2 or Thor 11 Thunder dror
strange 2 I really don't think Doctor
Strange 2 was a bad movie I don't know
why I get so much crap it wasn't what we
expected it definitely wasn't what I
expected it was going to be but I don't
think it was
bad 305 ryer no we have six
minutes BG believe me they will make
starts that sick returning him will be
like the second so they won't take that
lightly just Jam him into phase five
right so yeah I I don't think what what
was it it was Captain yeah I don't think
it's gonna be the next Captain America
movie
uh yeah I don't think so I think it's a
big secret Wars thing or something like
that
so yes Ryan Reynolds does know how to
write a good
story I hope you make it X-Men movies
they'll make it they might be
the the savior of the MCU right they
might be the actual Revival Adam yeah
yeah I you know I liked Multiverse of
Madness I it just wasn't what I thought
it was you know gonna
be do I think Bucky is in Brave New
World I think it would be weird if he
wasn't at least a cameo right I
mean yeah Lily uh Lou fandom mainly
Marvel I just it has so much going the
Marvel's has so much going against it
and now that there's like n like none of
the casts are promoting the film which
like so many people hate Brie Larson as
it is anyways I don't I really like her
actually but I almost wonder like is it
better that Bri Larson can't promote the
film or is it you know or should they be
promoting I don't I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know all right
this is the time if
uh people need to go to the
bathroom uh this is the time we have
four minutes coming up on three minutes
left sometimes they drop it a few
minutes early we're going to refresh
season two it's still not out yet but
this is the time because we're about to
go in
it Danny Campos who's who's director of
Secret Wars we don't know right now we
don't
know we really
Rafi do I
think John malovich can show up in
vulture variant to M Kang show up in
Deadpool 3 because of incursions and
battle World taking place you know I I
would it would make sense for King to
show up and that would be really cool I
wonder if John mov John malovich would
do that it's been a while since that uh
you know Spider-Man 4 movie got scrapped
with Sam Ramy and Toby I wonder if he
would still be down you know that would
be my only question
so
Multiverse amandes really was about
Wanda a lot yeah
yeah uh teamac yeah that's a tough one
you know one of my good buds um Eman
Emanuel uh I believe his Channel's
called Eman
reviews he he started the recast of
Chala movement and we've talked a lot
about that
um I think they should have recast
him um and it is weird you know they
didn't they recast William Hurt right
away but you know I don't I don't know
what goes on behind doors but I do think
they should have recast him they
essentially did recast him just in a
really weird way I would have just
rather him been recasted I get the what
they were trying to do but
still hey po hey appreciate you
appreciate you being here while you're
at work really do thanks for another
Super Chat yeah
um this is a good one no I just love
looki like as the series
what's up Jacob Wells hey appreciate
that yeah the community is good I will
say the community
exists because of you all and then a lot
of cool people that are creators as well
so hey appreciate you being a a follower
for so long really do thank you so much
Jacob uh I will say Spider-Man's going
to be a big part of Secret
Wars
and and the MCU after Secret Wars is
what I'll say all right two minutes two
minutes where am I here we
go it's not up yet keep refreshing oh
you know what I need to do I
don't I don't really know how to do this
I don't know how to put a timer I really
don't know how to put a
timer because what if F okay I got to
put this
here I gotta put this
here and then I gotta get this
pulled over here to be able
to to be able to do a little
uh actually where did it go oh no
technical
difficulties let's do that there we go
okay keep refreshing
it Leon what up
man oh thanks for coming member I super
appreciate that thanks so much
Leon not up
yet oh here it is I'm trying to get a
timer up trying to get a timer up trying
to get a timer up hold on let see if I
can do
this I think I used to like stopwatch
okay okay I can do this now is everyone
ready we're gonna do it okay start five
4 3 two one it's called breaking Brad
and I didn't real realized that before
and that's
hilarious I still can't figure this out
I don't remember how I did it last time
oh you know what it's not showing
anything because I'm not in hold on I'm
putting a pause sorry it's because I'm
not in
Chrome
that's why please don't make me log in I
won't remember anything yes
okay okay we're gonna try this again now
we're starting in three two one boom
sorry there we go all right so we're
gonna hit that recap real quick and I
cannot show as much this time because
last time it got oh no wait no is it
doing that thing where it's like
freezing
yeah it's not playing I might have to
play it
uh I might have to play
it come on
man it's not even moving now here I'll
show you guys my screen since it's not
working hold
on okay now it's
playing okay so this is where we're
at sorry
Jacob I would say just go for it the
internet is a place uh that that can be
hard but can also be very accepting by a
lot of people so know that it might be
kind of hard but if it's something you
really want to do you can totally do it
you totally can I promise you if I can
you can CU I'm really not that special
but but but uh thanks for being a
supporter glad I finally recognize you
as well and uh yeah do it man start your
own
channel got gotta hide some of
this see us but
Dan oh I got my chat put up here let's
just use
this here we
are all right this is where I'm at right
here sorry guys I cannot figure out what
I used to do for the timer I remember Mr
Anderson but I I can't figure out the
technical way to do it on
this because
like no it can't be
that sun
like like what is
this yeah I can't figure out we're just
going to have to show some scenes so
right now we're at
150 that's where we're
at there we go 1977
London
I like that part where he says this
place is too safe too safe for her to be
look at
ziac you're
itch Mr Wolf look it's
X5 oh I think I remember how I did
it
Bridget BAU she's a famous French uh
famous French
actress hold on I'm trying to figure
this
out
I don't think this is how I did it
before but I have an
idea
dang it it's not working the way I
wanted it to
work this is really not working in my
favor is
it
how about this there we go that that
could work
right it's kind of small
but
okay and oh what did I just hit oh no
and here comes
Loki with the Swagger that I wish wish I
had yeah I don't remember how to do that
Mr Anderson that's the problem I don't
remember how I did
that you're running from a god are we is
that right yeah five
minutes that's about right yeah it's
about where we're
at did you really think you outrun
me uh Malik Daredevil's not canceled
they're just rewriting it what up Frank
what's going on no for real life uh my
last stream got taken down because I
shared too much uh so now I can only
share like little Clips like this
unfortunately so oh I like this
part this is like classic 1970s like
London Punk guys I love
it it's funny that like he worked for
the TVA but he's still just a human you
know what I mean like he doesn't have
any
powers and boom it's an
illusion he said of
course nerd solves CES yeah the intro
does hit different I like this line
right
here it's not a fair
fight
I mean you're literally fighting a God
and has Guardian
God this part's really cool when the the
Shadows the Shadows behind him and they
grab him love
it no I can't really share much of it
unfortunately but why'd you
run
the people who always run are the people
who said I never did anything wrong
right mobus is right though why'd you
run and we're going into
it my timer is like a few seconds ahead
but this is basically where we're
at 7 minutes 30
seconds
and we in the
TVA hi rocket
hi what you
doing
that guy's intense D 100
D90 oh now they got
OB who's got a lot on his hands right
now
I know Mr Anderson I really like that
too I mentioned that on my
breakdown that he was talking to the
wrong
one
do you think this is a higher priority
than all of us dying than of the
temporal meltdown love
that
am I Mr Huge
leak I don't I I didn't hear about the
cancelling Vision Quest thing so I don't
know about that
one
I might have just figured out how to do
it I figured out how I did
it all right I think I can do
this
because now yeah now that's going to
do
there we
go got
it
Brad
wolf
most of all Brad's an a-hole
so this is where we're at right now oh I
in
deposit we're going into question good
old
bread why is this not
working
okay
why I'm all messed
up this
part these parts are really good
here uh I like Kang I I think Kang's
gonna be
awesome
seriously dude you were you left the TVA
and like went to the sacred
timeline anybody could arrest
you I wish the Star Wars collector I
wish this gets personal on this scene
right
here
I mean he is he is SL was a
villain
Loki is special you don't say so you
don't say
otherwise ooh the mother he brought his
mother into
this getting under his skin a little
bit you're a
villain and you're good at it not
wrong
Mobius is like what you getting at here
you're not bad you're good Loki you're
good
even 100 B15 is like what you about to
do cosmic Spider-Man I don't
know
hopefully it's a a word hole you're not
wrong
terrible awful
things do
one the music just abruptly stops he
needs
therapy just kill him
kill him
[Laughter]
Loki it's such a corny old joke but I
love it it fits Mobius
perfectly
you could be an
actor doesn't
matter it's not like they can go get
their old lives back
though
oh just wait Ramirez just wait for it
gets cool gets
cool it's kind of weird
man
get him
Mobius he call he calls him a silly
little
man I like how he's like oh Mobius
yes gota let that anger out sometimes
man
you were clearly ahead of
me some
pie Mobius love some
pie
good old key pie that is super green
that is so green every time I see the
scene I'm like it's so
green it's really
good he's such a great
character
I lost it it wasn't tactical yeah no
kidding
Mobius if he better Danny he better get
his jet
ski oh this is so funny remember that
time try to use the mindstone Tony dark
it didn't work I threw him off the
building he like you remember that
time where I did the whole plot of the
first Avengers
film that's
funny this this is deep because this is
how I would feel this hits really deep
deep thanks Fitness today appreciate
it yeah he can't go back to his old life
no one
can the the the timelines they came from
are definitely
pruned something
good I I just noticed that Loki is not
really eating the pie he's just eating
whipped
cream the way they get him to talk is so
good it's really cool really
creative exactly Mr Anis and he can't
can't go back so I get what he's saying
and yeah why would you want to know if
it was really good it's only going to
bum you
out yeah cuz she would have killed him
if he if she knew he found
her Brad wolf that's
funny here goes stiglets in uh season
one Mobius mentioned that he's always
wanted to write a jet
ski uh um he loves jet skis he says he
loves one of those things about Earth uh
of course he didn't know he was a
variant he thought it was created by TVA
so he kind of just worshiped jetskis
from afar so we all want to see him R of
jet
ski Obi Kyo Quan's character Kwan is an
actor for this character is
perfect
uhoh
uhoh access denied invalid temporal
Aura meaning you do not have the right
DNA it's password protected with
DNA
oh I did Mr Anderson oh I
did this part's so
good need another session because he
told him he needs
therapy something like
that
H BG that's pretty cool
man yeah ripped to the wallet though
right glad you got all that stuff to
though this stff this part's
cool watch how scared he get look how
scared he just starts to get I love it
he get he just gets gradually more
scared B15 is not
there Mrs rule book isn't there
he's not
wrong
uh Romero prod it's not that I was
changed is that it was never fit for him
you'll
see all right this part's
cool oh you in
trouble you in
[Music]
trouble
hey go
still I'll have to thank
Tyrone you must have watched some of his
reactions to my stuff tell him thank you
I'll tell him thank you too glad to see
you
here this part is really
cool
q& a it's
creative which should make you even more
scared that he doesn't know how to work
it
I love that I'm a villain
remember uh the timer is we are watching
Loki uh season two episode two right
now so watch
along I said some hurtful things and I
brought up your mother and I'm really
sorry about that that's
funny this is villain Loki and I love
it
I love
it look he's just messing with him
man you know you could kill me with that
could I love
it
look he's like that's
exciting hey thanks muffinry muffin man
appreciate
it uh I don't think so one more cast but
we'll have to
see I've done some terrible awful things
I love
Loki look at that smile
oh that Loki
[Laughter]
smile we are watching it right now this
this is kind of the best I can show you
all without getting
copyrighted oh that didn't work
this is the part we're
watching this is where we're
at this part's so cool they just keep
shrinking him in the
Box
I love
it you aren't de
either I love
it she has a new
life
got there in the
end and Mobius just opens the door he
wasn't locked out there's a PL there was
their plan the the whole
time oh this part's really cool this
part's really
cool uh yes YT strong gamer we are
watching it right now can kind of show
it to you here but this is
uh watch it right now we're at 30
minutes 31 seconds we're all going to
die
of
course I wrote
it so you wot the DVA guide book he's
like fanboying right
now a little cute moment little cute
moment
oh gross burn popcorn
no he who
remains so variant need a variant of
King
so convince Miss minutes to come back or
go find a variant of he who remains
which is where Victor timley comes
in
he wants to find
Sylvie
they're at the
McDonald's happy early birthday Malik
yeah that would be cool maybe in another
Universe hey thanks H go glitch
appreciate that and there she is our
Sylvie with our
Loki
stop
it Mobius needs his apple
[Laughter]
pie I love that music I love that
background music it's just so good like
that supposed to be like Asgardian Norse
you know mythology
music she does not want him to be
there happy early birthday Ty y tein
hope you have a good one my birthday is
the 29th this month getting close to
everyone's
birthday
gosh I remember those McDonald's
uniforms it's
hilarious
he's been time
slipping
why were you
there oh Ty well happy birthday
Ty yeah I had the looki meal for sure I
had the look meal at uh McDonald's
because you killed here
remains she hates the TVA still she
hates the TVA
still what's my real name my real name
is
Warren I do have a real
name see this right here Loki is
starting to believe that the TVA really
is
necessary for good meal
[Laughter]
they say opposites of track
no
then I kind of freaked out basically
tortured
you you slapped me in the face but I got
you a shake that's
funny it looked
scary
it's
Cinema is this a
setup
he's like nothing like convincing what's
up througha how's it
going kill
him
get
intense yeah me too Mr
Anderson
they're bombing the
timelines the
branches this part's cool you've seen
some of this Parts in the
trailers
oh yeah Malik I know uh yeah Tyrone
asked if he could do my videos and told
him yeah for sure
totally gotta kill that panel yeah Doc
is a
villain
I like that part where l throws the
prune stick at
him they're holding
hands but the damage is
done
oh I love that background
music
they killed almost all of the
branches there were a
lot it's like trillions of
people
yeah because Ren Slater had to bust out
of whatever timeline she was in before
it got
deleted yep she was in a branched
one say
mik
but the TVA could be fixed to be the
solution which is what Loki wants to
do man looki is just getting his heart
crushed over and over
again
o it it's got to be trillions of people
that died I mean right there's I mean
there's there's billions of people in
every
universe
so there they looked to be hundreds of
universes that got
pruned well her timeline's still there
because she's clearly there right now
and if you notice in the scene you'll
see it in a
second
is your mom on her way to pick you up
yeah look what she's got in her hand it
is he who remains his temp
pad and there you
go there it is
episode two what did everybody
think all right
let's get all my stuff back to normal
here what did everybody think of episode
two Loki season
yeah see that's that's why I like
avoided saying anything when y'all are
asking me about this episode like if it
was slow because it it is kind of slower
but it's really good still right like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I really like what's up Bruce schap
schmap sorry I don't know how to
pronounce that uh Marvel Zombies uh I
don't know I hope they do a lot of
different cool story lines you know kind
of like a a what if or if they're just
going to do a full you know one story
for the whole season I don't know but
I'm excited I think it'll be cool cool
Jack got games really sad they were too
late all the branches yeah so like if
you looked if you notice at the end like
pretty much all there were like hundreds
of Branch timelines hundreds maybe
thousands and there was only a like a
few left like two three left at the end
yeah
yeah I thought this episode I thought
that like the Box thing was really cool
right the way they kind of like tortured
him I thought that was pretty cool I
really did think that was
cool yeah I don't I don't mind like the
slower episodes that have dialogue and
stuff I think it's important to have
them you know it can't always be the
same Pace super super fast all the time
you know it can't always be that way I
will say oh I will say episode uh
three and and and four really pick up
the pace like a lot they pick up the
pace a lot and I really do like the next
two episodes a lot I like this episode a
lot too really do I think it overall was
like really
good yeah wondering Seth yeah I I
thought that too like well Loki loses
how can he use that to his Advantage
right I think Loki should take over the
TVA I think that's going to
happen Tate who the heck was Brad Brad
was Hunter
X5 the guy that was the
actor AV really glad you're liking it
Danny glad you're liking it what was she
holding at the end didn't I didn't get a
good look ja that was he who remains his
temp pad that he used in the finale of
Loki season one
so yeah oh cool Elite you like this
episode better than the first
nice nice nice nice uh what day uh
Weezy see Weezy Nikki um it just
premiered for us I'm in the uh us
here um in the states so just premiered
for us and I think it's in India and hot
Star right now too I think it comes out
at the same time not sure where you're
at yeah see you nerd loves cubes solves
cubes nerd solves cubes
sorry see you glad you enjoyed the
episode yeah po glad you liked it glad
you liked it yeah this man lowy really
is just
a oh my gosh I forgot I have this Miss
minutes clock here it kind of freaked me
out for a second it's all blurred in the
background I totally forgot about
totally forgot about that wow
yeah good Billy Bug entertainment slow
but good
good oh really that's funny Luffy man
that's
funny deanb I'd love to see Loki Reed
Richard strange maybe Professor X as
their own little group looking after a
timeline I think that that's what secret
War should be is and I I put this in a
video I think Loki should run the TVA
and get together a big multiversal group
of Heroes to monitor when Kang is going
to pop out so they can kill Kang right
away before he becomes too powerful that
way they can have the entire
Multiverse without killing without
pruning all the timelines so
yeah Jake I you know I'm not sure uh
what Chris is planning to do uh with
watch parties and stuff like that
because I know he streams on Twitch now
so I'm not really sure bud I'll find out
and let you know next week no post
credit scene con no no post credit
scene yeah the very last podcast this
episode left me with so many questions
yeah
[Music]
um I will say lowkey season 2 what I've
seen so far is really really good at
Cliffhangers so keep that in mind as you
go
forward uh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah um I think it's Ms
minutes but
I I could be wrong I've actually never
thought about that good
question is a missing yeah she's there
in my room right
there
you think sylv's gonna run it yeah I I
was thinking Sylvie Patrick I was
thinking Sylvie and and Loki would run
it together I hope I hope they can
get some type of closure maybe be
together some type of a happy ending
with each other but you know who knows
Loki is unmatched yeah th this
uh I love the show I I loved season one
so much and I like the show a lot and I
understand it might not be for everybody
some people are like you know why does
everybody love the show so much I don't
know I just think it's
fantastic I just think it's fantastic
Emma glad you liked
it uh I think he realizes Mina that Loki
or that Sylvie took him out which is why
all the branches were happening I think
I think she and she was trying to kill
him the entire time and then she got rid
of him so I I I'm pretty sure he
knows
hey Erin wraths uh I really like this
episode yeah I I so here's what I'll say
I was avoiding saying this before the
show started because I didn't want to
ruin the episode for anybody this was
this is probably my least favorite
episodes out of the four that I've seen
I didn't want to say that before because
you might have thought this episode is
Bad when it's not bad it's a good
episode it's a really good episode but
the others I think are fantas fantastic
so we'll
see yeah 305 Rider I thought about that
a Deadpool Cameo since the TVA is
supposed to be a big part of Deadpool uh
I don't know we'll have to see really
the the direction they take it in
episode five and six we'll have to
see yeah I think this is uh
yeah ebony D young yeah I I think it was
a good comic relief from X5 but yeah I
love watching Owen Wilson and Tom hson
together they're so great they're so
great yeah it had a lot of depth to it
this episode had a lot of depth to it it
really did and I think those episodes
are necessary I really do I think it
fits uh well yeah Mr Anderson the the
writing for this is better than most and
I think that's why it's good I think
Marvel needs to focus more on the on the
writing I really
do we're all going to die nice me yeah
Chaz I thought that was funny dud his
character is fantastic and he gets
better as it goes
on yeah exactly Jack ey games you can't
always have that fast Bas but uh all
right guys I have to the the breakdowns
pretty much done there's a few things I
have to do including the thumbnail stuff
like that but the breakdown should be up
uh let me actually check real quick to
see how far
along yeah the breakdown should be up
it's a little over 26 minutes uh I'm
just going to get some things finalized
with it and then it should be up in
about 20 minutes 20 30 minutes uh so
yeah yeah so glad everybody really liked
this episode gonna bounce gonna jump off
real quick so I can get this breakdown
out for everybody uh but yeah really
glad to to see everyone liked it and
can't wait till y'all watch the next
couple episodes because uh I I think
episode four is the could be the best oh
I don't want to say that but three is
really good um and I think four could be
the best episode so we'll see we'll see
but be excited for the next ones because
I think everyone's since you since
everyone really enjoyed the first two I
think they're really going to enjoy the
next two so I'll see you all here next
week and like I said my breakdown is
going to be out in about 20 to 30
minutes I would say so I'm get working
on that right now uh thank you Mr
Anderson for modding today super
appreciate it thank you to everybody who
stopped by thank you to everybody for
the super chats if you donated really
appreciate the whole Community as in
general these watch parties are great
I'm glad they're I'm glad they're at a
decent time now so we could start them
back up again so awesome uh thank you
everybody really do appreciate that uh
look out for that video and I'll see you
all next week and the next